we made at the airport I'm on my way
home to Pittsburgh Oh No
Maddie found another dog I'm on my way
home to Pittsburgh and then I'm going to
New York
oh look at you found a friend he keeps
seeing dogs and kids and all I wants to
do is something with everybody I'd like
but we can't do that he's so thirsty
and we made it first up is the doggy
restroom it is so amazing that this burg
has this it's just like this great
little doggie relief area I wish every
year what happens are you ready to go
ahh
how do I turn up this on to get it but
no you can't be done did you show your
hair first it was intensive
baby
Oh
Wow
the way I keep my hands to myself okay
parents downslope area we care about
Falls hi everyone so I'm home in
Pittsburgh as you saw probably from the
previous clips of me on a plane with the
dog
traveling with Maddie is quite the
experience it was the first time that
I've traveled with him in a really long
time he's cute without Jenna so I was
all by myself
we're now on the way to pick up Brie's
wedding dress can you believe it
No
yeah yeah what's a great dancer I don't
know yeah I can believe it I couldn't
believe it can you because we're doing
it I looked at but but but guys like
what what what do you dump like a one
truck truck all night long are you gonna
play that here wedding if you didn't
sure okay
we need to add that to the playlist and
it just that's all on repeat also some
DMX got it with DMX the team s was
coming didn't even wait in my bed to my
tweets I was so upset guys I really
wanted the a Mexican every what idea
mess and say why aren't you coming to my
wedding yes that would be amazing
because I really think that he would be
really great so matter
should we listen to you man could i how
do I play music through here I don't
even know there's like a cordon where I
don't do any of that
do you know music check the other pocket
we do he's not come my wedding we're
fighting there's still time there's
still time
there's still time everyone tweet him
tell dia by subdivers wedding is
Twitter's at DMS Bree Bree Bree the
pharmacy there's great hi ye I only
ended up with three items and Julian
necessary for this basket so I'm just
gonna pick some up the one thing that we
needed forgot
audio cable so you can listen to DMX we
need to hurry we're late for what I
don't like that you're more like a with
a headphone jack you don't have any
audio cables but I don't think she
actually what I was talking about that's
crazy
we almost always have them places big
day big day today
breakup job
no no no no closed eyes oh gosh no I
gotta get out I was like what'd you get
me
I'll get out this place free where are
we sucking down that on that wedding
diet I'm just joking I actually gained
weight for the wedding
it'll be okay Bri it looks very pretty
like a little princess
Thanks now what do we do it too much no
this is good coffee your windows open
cause good tonight bring it honestly I
turn in just like this annoying person
when I'm with you because I just like I
just wanna mention you're so upset with
me when we're shopping for your wedding
jewelry you were so disrespectful to
bring in you were not helping you put
you off a trend with less we're at
Macy's remember and I can't find a lot
ugly stuff for you I don't know I just I
honestly like you out so we had a great
time today picking up freeze dress and
doing all kinds of fun errands and I
came home to a box of socks so what
happened is I realized I forgot to bring
sucks home for my two weeks of traveling
and well I made a mistake because I
didn't actually read the Amazon
descriptions of what I was buying so I
thought it was like one bag of sauce and
one bag of socks what I didn't realize
it was actually all of these packs of
sauce so I'm set for two weeks and the
rest of my life also another very
exciting thing happened I got the
phantom 4 drone and I hadn't sent here
to my parents house so that while I'm
back from Brie's wedding and I've got
some time here I'll be able to fly it
without fear of too many obstacles like
buildings so I did the unboxing and I'm
going to finish that video which will be
up for next week's check Tuesday so I'm
quite excited about that tonight we're
going to the pens game hopefully they
win so I'm gonna go get dressed
my mom's ironing my shirt cuz I was
gonna wear it wrinkled and she said no
where's baby boy going out for you walk
his little Tommy's been bothering him
and it breaks my heart he puked on the
floor right there it's gone now
constantly worrying about the dog
it's kind of chilly out yeah wait about
a hot chocolate hot chocolate here
Martin oh my oh my that was fast breathe
really concerned
boy things are really heating up
chatting like drink here's my snapchat
these are my grand out here on the front
line stare at my grant all of them more
that's my free
Oh
it's just in there out of good way out
of hell Pizza okay
I've been having such a wild time here
at the game I've had me like five times
more like 50 times I
Hey okay
we watch perceptual sorry it's over I
have nothing else for you bye what a
great game it was so much fun
now we have to drive home and I actually
took my contacts out so I can't see
anything
hey Jeff on foot yapping I'm gonna open
this up so I can take you guys outside
and for a test drive of it